So this is the idea.
Essentially,
you know that you have the unknown world
that that's just what you don't know at
all.
That's,
that's the outside,
that's the ocean that
surrounds the island,
that you inhabit something like that.
It's chaos itself and then you act in
that world and you act in ways you don't
understand.
There's more to your actions.
Then you can understand.
One of the things young said,
I love this.
When I first understood it,
he said,
everybody acts out a myth,
but very few people know what their myth
is and you should know what your myth
is because it might be a tragedy
and maybe you don't want it to be,
and that's really worth
thinking because thinking about,
because you're,
you have a pattern of behavior
that characterizes you,
you know,
and God only knows where you got it.
Partly it's biological,
partly it's from your parents.
It's,
it's your unconscious assumptions.
It's the way the philosophy of your
society is shaped you and it's,
it's aimed,
it's aiming you somewhere.
Well,
is it aiming you somewhere you want to go?
That's a good question.
That's part of self realization.
You know,
we know we don't understand our actions.
That's an almost every argument you
have with someone is about that.
It's like,
why did you do that and come up with
some half baked reasons why you did it.
You're flailing around in the darkness.
You know,
you try to give an account for yourself,
but you can only do it partially.
It's very,
very difficult because you're in your,
you're a complicated animal with the
beginnings of an articulated mind,
something like that,
and you're just way more
than you can handle.